and I thought to myself you about to
find out
I shall create after that nap totally
refreshed ready to Blackmail that Indian
chick
all right people it is June 26
2023. that's right it's my birthday I'm
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report we
are live streaming on rumble on locals
and on YouTube we have a tremendous
program for you everyone in the room is
very excited everyone has promised me
none of their usual screw-ups or errors
today everyone's going to work real hard
to give you guys a perfect show I said
to them this morning I have everything I
want in this world there's nothing else
that I want I'm good to go really I've
got it all life is good I just want the
perfect birthday show for the good
people and that is what we are going to
deliver for you today of course we do
have a post game show if you'd like to
join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and I want to
thank everybody for all the kind
birthday wishes I am checking everything
I cannot respond to absolutely
everything but I do appreciate it we had
a staff dinner here on so was that
Saturday night and uh I cooked a 15
pound brisket for these people and we
had a little bit of tequila and there's
nothing else that I can say about it
online so there we go uh the show today
is going to be about what has happened
to the crazy liberals they have all Gone
Bananas as you know but then there's a
few Rebels trying to stick around and
make sure the left doesn't go completely
insane I know a little something about
this it's sort of what my hero's journey
has been all about my life story and the
new guy stepping into that right now
obviously is Robert F Kennedy Jr and he
was on Bill Maher's podcast Club random
over the weekend and they talked about
what has happened to the nems what has
happened to the Liberals how have they
become so illiberal is there any chance
they could come back why
John F Kennedy Robert F Kennedy's uncle
would probably well I don't think they
quite said he would probably be a
republican but really wouldn't be a
Democrat if he was still around today so
we are going to unpack the craziness of
the left-wing agenda and
little teaser I've got a newspaper here
an actual physical copy of a newspaper
I'll explain why in just a moment but
let's talk about my Patriot Supply and
then get to it guys if you think you
won't need emergency food think again
the government recently revealed the
truth about impending food shortages
according to the USDA countless of
America's annually planted crops in
Bread Basket States won't be harvested
this season extreme weather conditions
and worldwide fertilizer shortages wiped
them out that means food will become
scarce and expensive is your family
prepared for that if not now is the time
to stock up on emergency food from our
friends at my Patriot Supply at discount
prices but hurry this is a limited time
offer and it expires soon go to prepare
with reuben.com to save big on each
four-week emergency food kit you need
for your family each Kit's packed with
delicious energy boosting breakfasts
lunches dinners drinks and snacks that
everyone will love act now for massive
savings on each kit you need go to
prepare with reuben.com and place your
order before the deadline you'll never
forgive yourself if you let your family
suffer go to prepare with reuben.com
right now and now back to me okay so
let's just dive into it now you know my
policy
you're a fan of the Reuben report you
like the Reuben report you know what
we're doing over here my policy on on
Bill Maher has been I'd like to take him
as far as I could get him and then he's
gonna have to make that last little move
I don't know that he can do it like is
he really going to vote for DeSantis or
he's certainly not going to vote for
Trump or whatever but like you want to
nudge accordingly that has been my
policy and also you know he just
represents the idea of the old liberal
but many of you are the old school
liberal many of you may be thinking
about voting Republican for the first
time or at least leaving the Democrat
Party there's a massive amount of people
doing that not only doing that but
literally picking up and leaving blue
cities and states and moving to Red
cities and states and all that so Bill
Maher had RFK Jr right now RFK Jr has
been getting hit over and over and over
by the mainstream media by the corporate
press by all the covid crazy people the
whole freaking thing here they are
talking about how the left has left
liberals you think I know a little
something about this
let me ask you something yeah I know
you know something happened to liberals
who are fellow liberals yes
um and whatever it was yes accelerated
Amplified during the pandemic I was not
on board with how we handled covid uh I
yeah but what was your what was your
Evolution like when did you say a long
time ago I was I was on 16 minutes
quoted me like in 20 2009 or something
saying uh I wouldn't get a flu shot not
because I don't believe I'm not talking
about vaccines so much
but just on what was happening in covid
you know with the lockdowns first of all
what one thing I don't understand about
the covet thing is how come I mean I'm
sure you know about the Great Barrington
letter that was signed by 16 000 doctors
and scientists who were all dissenting
about how we were handling it how come
your doctors only count I'm not talking
to you I'm talking to the Western
medicine how come your doctors they're
the ones that's the science and like if
it was one guy out there but it's like a
lot of accredited people so like I think
that is one reason why you came out of
the gate at 20 because it's just a lot
more people in this country who were on
to that kind of thing and how much
Medics Medical Science conventional
mission is wrong and gets things wrong
including about covet lots of things
they got wrong okay so I know you
watching that are like yes duh but
you're still voting for the wrong people
so be it let's put that aside for a
second the idea that two self-pro
proclaimed liberals in 2023 can sit
there and be frustrated with the covered
rollout I mean I don't know during covid
how much Bill was fighting it but we all
woke up to a certain degree and he's
become good on it so let's give him a
little bit of pass on that right
everybody gets that that leash I always
say like you get at least a month Leash
from the two weeks to flatten the curve
or the 15 days to flatten the curve
whatever it was it's like I'll give even
a little bit more than that and then we
all sort of woke up to whatever extent
that we did now what RFK Jr is saying
and by the way you probably know this
already I've mentioned it a couple times
he's like really embedded in sort of the
liberal Hollywood Elite machine his wife
is Cheryl Hines who plays Larry David's
now ex-wife on Curb Your Enthusiasm I
mean she's been on many many sitcoms I
mean she's a big Hollywood star so he's
saying to him well when did you realize
this all went crazy throughout covid and
Bill is upset with the doctors right
because you should have all along all
along instead of these the idea of
mandates the idea of forced vaccinations
not letting people go out and everything
else and staying home and eat and take
out and all of that stuff everyone
should have been like well actually I'm
35 I'm relatively healthy I live in a
warm weather area where I can get some
sun and vitamin D all of the stuff that
we now know now the issue here why I'm
showing you this video is what they're
talking about right there is very much
outside of the mainstream of democrat
policy right it was the Democrats when
Biden came in that wanted the mandates
they wanted people to be fired from
their jobs they wanted vaccine passports
and by the way Republicans don't get off
scot-free with this right they went
along with an awful lot of it not all of
them and there were some places that
pushed that freedom thing a little bit
right I happen to be living in one of
those places right now but the point is
that the people who now question covid
science the people who question trans
radical ideology gender queer stuff all
of that a really outside of the Democrat
Party right now and it's for guys like
RFK Jr and Bill Maher to figure out okay
am I going to keep voting for a party
that actually I'm just railing against
all day long because you know what
happens when you question Democrat Dogma
you get called a radical right-winger
there's a guy by the name of Elon Musk
who had basically only voted for
Democrats his entire life no one in
their right mind would have ever thought
he was a conservative by any traditional
definition or anything else but Elon
Musk started talking about Free Speech
right so here they are talking about
covid now they are outside the Democrat
thing Elon Musk started talking about
Free Speech then he got pushed out of
the Democrat thing here's RFK and Bill
Maher talking about just that
you consider Elon Musk right away no I I
consider myself
I consider him a genius well that's
obvious but he's all his heart's in the
right place but I think by his own
admission he's a little Specter me and
he he does some cuckoo things that you
just have to accept in him and they seem
fairly benign in the J in the general
even though they are you know head
Smacker like why did you say that or
what was that really necessary to
whatever but uh in general I think if
anybody's going to figure out like I got
to save the planet kind of we
should be we should like not piss off
people like that
okay
first off I don't know about the kooky
things that Elon Musk has said all he
basically has said is that he's you know
buying Twitter to defend free speech
he's also trying to get us to other
planets and doing a whole bunch of other
stuff but the point is by defending Free
Speech if you now look at the way say
the New York Times and CNN and corporate
president everything treat Elon Musk
he's now on the right right remember Ron
DeSantis launched his presidential
campaign on Twitter spaces with Elon
Musk so everyone said he must be an evil
Republican then then Elon Musk said well
anyone any candidate is welcome to do
this with me the only other one who's
taking him up on it is Robert F Kennedy
Jr so you can see what's happening here
this concept though of that once you say
literally anything you could live your
entire life as a good decent liberal
behaving the way they want you to behave
and everything else but once you take
one slight deviation be it covid be it
free speech if you don't want
eight-month abortions if you believe
that boys are boys and girls or girls
once you take that little deviation the
idea of how the machine will come
crashing down on you uh is something
that I've been fascinated with for many
years because it's something that has
repeatedly happened to me so now I want
to show you a newspaper you might
remember these things newspaper they're
made on paper with print and you can get
ink on your fingers this is a very old
school way of reading the news this
particular paper is from Sunday June 9th
2019 so almost four years ago to the day
my man Chris who does our YouTube and
Rumble back end stuff we had the team
here as I said for a birthday dinner on
Saturday night Chris flew in from New
York
lives in New York I don't know why he's
got his own reasons uh and he gave me
this paper and the reason he gave me
this paper was because we're going to
show you some closer images in just a
sec on this paper this was a Sunday
paper New York Times and the title of
the main article here was the making of
a YouTube radical how the site's
algorithms played into the hands of the
alt-right and there were images there of
Jordan Peterson there's an image of Milo
when he was on the Reuben report it even
says Reuben report back there there's
Ben Shapiro there right in the middle
that's Milton Friedman right Milton
Friedman Nobel prize winning libertarian
Economist pushing people to be alt right
and now go to page 20 this was the
exciting one for me yeah there I am
making of a YouTube radical algorithms
and the alt-right and the entire article
is basically that YouTube and big Tech
were pushing people to the right but do
you see how I'm connecting this to the
other thing because first off we all
putting it putting all that aside for a
second we know that's all right we know
that over the last couple years big Tech
has repeatedly silenced people on the
right Amplified people on the left
anyone who even considers themselves a
liberal but then asks any questions gets
taken out and demonetized and de-boosted
and all of those things and anyway so
Chris gave me this paper for my birthday
and I thank you for this Chris we are
going to frame it and put it up because
it's a beautiful moment now but four
years after that now seeing what they're
doing to RFK every day there's another
hit piece about him we showed you the
headline last week they went after his
wife they were like Cheryl Hines has
been a well-known Hollywood actress but
now her husband's dangerous ideas are
making her question but it's just like
this is what they do with everything
what do I always say guys truth is a
Time release pill so a certain amount of
people believe this right a certain
amount of you know these New York Times
people and what do they do it's a Sunday
and they have their coffee
oh my God Dave Rubin is scary and that
Milton Friedman killed my family it's
it's absolutely insane but the truth
eventually gets out there and I think
now what's happening is despite all the
lies the average person and you can see
it in the polls as RFK is on his way up
the average person is like wait a minute
wait a minute we've had it with the
lying we've had it you guys have lied to
us about literally everything this guy
seems pretty decent uh let's find out a
little bit more about him and now let's
throw to one more clip on this uh this
is Bill and RFK talking about uh sort of
Classical liberalism how that was
related to Robert F Kennedy's Uncle John
F Kennedy and what has happened to the
Democrats you consider yourself a
Democrat no I never said I was in either
one I always was careful to say I do
caucus with the Democrats I I was a a
liberal and old school liberal not a
woke liberal
um
but Kennedy Democrat a Kennedy Democrat
and an Obama democrat
oh bill you almost had it right yes a
Kennedy Democrat asked not what the
country can do for you ask what you can
do for your country right that is a
Kennedy Democrat scaling back War
lowering taxes equality over Equity that
is the Democrat that you are but then
you suddenly say the Obama thing and
Obama is the one who put wokeness and
Equity Equity really more than anything
else on steroids and then pushed it into
the system that leaves us uh exactly
where where we are at right now so I'll
get to that in just a second let me talk
to you about pravia hair are you one of
the millions of American women and men
of any age dealing with premature
thinning and hair loss or maybe you're
scared about inheriting that thinning
look just because it runs in the family
well guys there's a real solution that
delivers on its own promise without
harsh side effects unwanted chemicals
and unpleasant smells thanks to our
friends that developed geniusell skin
care pravia uses a safe natural
ingredient procapital to effectively
Target the three main causes of
premature thinning and loss by
supporting healthy scalp circulation the
delivery of nourishing nutrients and
healthy hair follicle anchoring to your
scalp provia guarantees more hair on
your head than in the shower or on the
comb that's pretty good effective for
men and women of any age and safe on
color treated and styled hair it's that
easy and right now customers can save
over 50 percent off provides
introductory package at previahair.com
Dave every package includes a 60-day
supply of pravia serum for daily use
plus pravia 30 super concentrate for
faster more noticeable results provia
Works guaranteed or 100 of your money
back see for yourself right now don't
wait proviahair.com Dave proviahair.com
Dave and now back to me okay so Bill
Maher you kinda had it right now I get
it you're going to vote the wrong way no
matter what you don't realize that the
party's gone completely insane but you
sort of had it I'm an old full liberal
right I believe in individual rights I
believe in equality the government maybe
could do a couple things but shouldn't
do everything let's ease up on the Wars
all right blah blah blah blah blah but
then he says I'm also an Obama
Democrat now what does an Obama democrat
mean well uh Obama's been in the news
he's been making the rounds the last
couple days because I think they are
realizing that the Biden thing's
breaking down and they got to figure out
what the next move is I don't know if
the next move is Gavin I don't know if
the next move is Michelle Obama or
something but they're just putting other
voices out there because clearly having
Joe Biden as the head of the party as
RFK is rising it's not working for
anybody everybody knows this is nonsense
so here's a little bit from an interview
that Obama did over the weekend talking
about uh well well you know what just
watch it yourself I painted I've painted
too much enjoy our democracy is not
going to be healthy with the levels of
inequality that we've seen generated
from globalization automation
uh the decline in unions
obscene inequality you think about
news of the day generally we're not
talking about news of the day but right
now we have
a 24-hour coverage
and I understand it of this submarine
the submersible
that tragically is right now lost at the
bottom of the sea
um
at the same time right here in at just
off the coast of Greece we had 700
people dead 700 migrants who were
apparently being smuggled uh into here
and yeah we've it's made news but it's
not dominating in the same way and and
in some ways it's indicative of the
degree to which
people's life chances have have grown so
disparate
it's very hard to sustain a democracy
when you have such massive
concentrations of wealth
such perfect Obama because it all sounds
right and he looks good and the suit
fits and on first glance it all sort of
makes sense and then of course as you
guys know you just have to peel that
thin veneer and you can see the nonsense
by it first up he's obsessed with
obscene inequality obscene inequality
now Barack Obama was a community
organizer before he was a Senator and
then president and uh somehow he's now
worth like hundreds of millions of
dollars obscene inequality how about a
little obscene inequality in Martha's
Vineyard yeah there's Obama's 30-acre
estate on the water in Martha's Vineyard
and you may remember when uh Ron
DeSantis sent 30 uh illegal immigrants
not migrants he sent 30 of them to
Martha's Vineyard Obama could have given
each one of them an acre or he could
have housed 30 people on an acre they
would have had plenty of room but he did
not and he also apparently doesn't fear
climate change because he lives right on
the water but you see what he did there
so ah you see we're focusing on this
submarine as opposed to these migrants
well guess what Greece is a country
it is a Sovereign Nation just like the
United States is a Sovereign Nation you
are allowed to protect your borders any
which way you want the 700 people I have
great sympathy obviously for for anyone
that dies doing trying to better their
life or whatever you have human Sympathy
for the lives that are lost of course
but we should be focusing on that we
should just be focusing on that as
opposed to anything else it's like well
what if Greece didn't want these people
to be there what if Greece is for Greek
people like could we talk about that but
he doesn't really want us to think about
that because most importantly guys
Barack Obama who again lives on the
water in one of the most exclusive
places in the United States on a 30-acre
estate how he got all that money I'm not
sure Netflix something something uh he's
very very worried about climate change
which again I don't know if he knows the
water is going to hit him first over
there at that house or whatever but here
he is on China and climate change
you know I dealt with China to get the
Paris Accords done I dealt with Modi to
get prepare supports done because I
think climate change is something that
transcends uh you know any particular
momentary issues it's a it's a problem
that Humanity's got to deal with over
the next several decades in a serious
way
um I do think that it is appropriate for
the president United States
where he or she can
to uphold
those principles and to challenge uh
whether behind closed doors or in public
trends that are troubling and so I'm
less concerned about labels that I'm
concerned about you know specific
practices
just nothing it's just well packaged
drivel the Paris Accords you know what
happened with the Paris Accords the
Paris Accords were this giant sort of
Consortium of countries that came
together to cut emissions and blah blah
most of it fell on the United States and
we were of course footing the bill on
the whole thing Obama signed it one of
the first things that Donald Trump did
to his credit was get rid of the thing
and it was non-binding it was a
non-binding agreement so it's a perfect
liberal document here's a whole bunch of
things you the United States will have
to pay the price no one there's no
mechanism to punish anyone or make sure
that any other country is doing
absolutely anything but you liberals
will all feel good as you're having your
parties with your champagne on Martha's
video oh my God you signed that document
wonderful wonderful this is what they do
with absolutely everything also it was
interesting there when he said uh well
over the next couple decades we'll have
to worry about climate change AOC four
years ago we got seven years to live we
we showed you that tweet since deleted
tweet from Greta thundberg uh from five
years ago where she said we had five
years to live it's all Bs nonsense and
even if you believe that the climate is
changing which by the way the climate
does change you're not gonna believe
this it rained yesterday and then an
hour later it was sunny here holy cow we
better uh we better shut down the cars
even if you believed any of that the
idea that these people would be able to
do any these people couldn't run a
business if their life depended on it
that they are going to be the ones that
are going to save you from the climate
they're just BS artists and now to prove
what an extraordinary BS artist Barack
Obama is under the most light questions
possible he went on this show I'm not
even sure is this The Daily Show what
show is this even does anyone even know
it's some random show on Comedy Central
this guy Hassan Minaj asking Obama about
his favorite books shows and songs and
watch how he is so afraid to say
anything I cannot believe they aired
this evening you just cannot say
anything true
Mr President
when you do your end of the year lists
yes
do you really
read all those books watch all those
shows and listen to all those songs I
am so glad that I had this opportunity
please
people they they believe
the the books and the movies
but the playlists they somehow think and
this is mostly coming from young people
like you yeah somehow y'all think you
invented rock and roll you invented
hip-hop and so the fact that
my lists
are
you know pretty incredible you have Life
Is Good by Sir featuring scribs Riley on
your iPhone brand new come on man don't
don't play with me okay okay huh all
right let's cap it let's cap it let's
let's raise the rim a little bit
give me the plot line for afterlives by
Abdul razak gurna
dude how much time do we have here
I mean I can't believe they aired that I
genuinely can't believe they heard that
like he's he's an unbelievable liar and
artist like his end-of-year
playlist are made up when I get my
Spotify playlist at the end of the year
what songs do you listen to the most I
can tell you every single one of those
songs because I actually listen to them
he makes up the books and movies that he
watches I am shocked credit to this
Hassan Minaj guy like you actually it
was sort of funny and whatever you know
it's interesting though when we were
playing that clip Brock said to me that
he thinks for young people that makes
Obama look good because it makes him
look relatable because you think they're
all just like oh he's a artist
like we're all artists
something like that is that what it is
we lack critical thinking young people
lack critical thinking skills so that
makes them look human this is a problem
that's my point just terrible but you
see that it's like so when he lies about
that it's like you know he and he's just
so smooth in his lying and you didn't
watch these movies or anything else
anyway let's continue though because
again what's what got us to this point
in the show we were talking about the
sort of good decent liberal ideas that
are that are I think the right ideas but
just have nothing to do with the modern
Democrat then you have someone like Bill
Maher saying I'm an Obama guy well we
just punched some holes in some Obama
stuff well what else is going on with
the rest of the Democrats well uh noted
Crypt Keeper Nancy Pelosi uh who is no
longer the Speaker of the House thank
you Lord uh was on Jen saki's Show on
MSNBC jensaki of course former White
House Press Secretary who is terrible at
her job so then you get a job at a fake
mainstream media corporate press Outlet
the televised mental institution known
as MSNBC here is saki asking Pelosi what
she would do to the Supreme Court
because she don't she didn't like that
court because she didn't control it and
that's upsetting to these people because
they're all authoritarian Maniacs video
clip
do you think that there should be
changes reforms to the Supreme Court
term limits an expansion yeah I don't
know that's expanding it's been over 150
years since we've had an expansion of
the Court it was in the time of Lincoln
that went up to nine so the subject of
whether that should happen is a a
discussion and it's not a say a rallying
cry but it's a discussion uh the
president formed a commission they did
not recommend expansion of the court
that shouldn't be the end of it but
there certainly should be term limits
there's certain reasons and if nothing
else there should be some ethical rules
that would be followed I had one Justice
tell me he thought the other justices
were people of Integrity like a Clarence
Thomas I'm like get out of here she's
really disgusting like how can I even
comment on this Clarence Thomas is not
an ethical man like
lady if you if this was the other side
you'd be being called racist just for
saying that which you're allowed to
criticize anyone of any skin color
without being racist but like the idea
that we would change the nature of the
Court what she's saying is oh sometimes
the court sometimes these people who get
to the most important court in the land
make decisions based on law that I as a
legislator don't like I legislate the
law I write the laws right the president
signs them into law and then the courts
look at them and they go is this legal
is this uh congruent with the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights and
things like that and she doesn't like
that she doesn't have the ultimate power
to do it so this is why Democrats are
always saying let's pack the courts the
court doesn't have the makeup that we
like right now let's add more judges and
what they mean by more judges is they
add more people that will do what we
want them to do let them have in essence
write law from the court that's not what
you want right that's Banana Republic
level stuff but but the whole party has
been overtaken with these crazy ideas
they just say things and they think
because they say them they're
automatically true here is the wizard
the absolute wizard that is vice
president right now Kamala Harris and
she put out this video over the weekend
because it's the one year anniversary of
the reversal of Roe v Wade now remember
also it's funny that the year flew by
that quick because remember everybody
said there's going to be all these dead
people and dead children and they're not
that concerned about dead babies but all
of this stuff we haven't heard much of
anything right we haven't heard much of
anything about any of it states made
decisions and people act accordingly
anyway here's Kamala Harris giving a
really insightful commentary on the year
since Roe v Wade has flipped
so that day the day that the Supreme
Court took a constitutional right from
the women of America that was outraged
in fact the first person I called was my
husband
um because I could just let it all out
with him and my first thoughts really
were about our daughter
my niece my baby nieces my goddaughters
and what this all might mean I mean for
our daughter she is going to know fewer
constitutional rights than my
mother-in-law and so I think we all at
that moment understood how dire it would
be one year later the majority of
Americans are with us from so-called red
states to Blue States from Kentucky to
California when this issue was on the
ballot in the midterms the people voted
in favor of allowing women to have the
choice
about what happens to their body so
going forward let's not throw up our
hands let's roll up our sleeves
President Biden and I will not stop
fighting to make sure that every woman
has the right and the choice
to make decisions about her own body
okay the easy stuff first this this
concept that they care about your right
and your choice to make decisions over
your own body these are the same
freaking people who two years ago were
demanding that you get injected with a
quote-unquote vaccine that was actually
not a vaccine that nobody knew if it
worked and in essence it really didn't
work at all and now there's all sorts of
people with vaccine injuries and they
were telling you that you should get
fired from your job or not be able to
work at the federal government or not be
able to go out in public in a whole
series of other crazy things if you
didn't do what they wanted so you got to
spare me the my body my choice part the
other thing and she's a perfect it's a
carbon copy this is what they all do and
I really think that if enough of us
start just seeing it just start seeing
through it and then and then we can
operate accordingly she does the exact
same thing that that Obama does it's
like you speak sort of com you know
usually Democrats are screaming and
throwing things in everyone's outrage
and everything else the other version of
it is they speak very calmly as they're
just lying to you right so she he's
saying that they the Supreme Court took
away a constitutional right that is 180.
the reverse of what the Supreme Court
did the point of the reversal of Roe v
Wade was that there is no constitutional
right to an abortion in the Constitution
itself right it's not written in the
Constitution
that you should have a right to an
abortion so thus the court looked at it
and Roe v Wade which was about whether
it should be Federal right that there
should be a federal mandate related to
abortion all they did was reverse it
they looked at the Constitution this is
what the judges did I mean it's so
simple but they lie they looked at the
Constitution and said well there is no
federal right there's no right there's
an abortion in the Constitution I mean
we looked we didn't see the word
abortion it's just not there so this is
not something that the federal
government has the right to be telling
the states what to do so all it did was
kick it back to the States so her
daughter that she's worried about and
her niece they don't have less rights
than her mother-in-law you now can live
in a state that has abort first off
every state has abortion right now uh no
State outlawed it with no restrictions
but even if there was a state that
absolutely outlawed it with no
restrictions or whatever else or if you
felt that the six-week ban in Florida is
too much you can go to Cali and have an
eight-month abortion I literally I swear
to God I got a text you know you just
get on these stupid lists the Democrats
sideways to get your phone number I got
a text from some New York law I think I
deleted it from some like New York
abortion company or non-profit or
whatever asking if I would donate money
so that they could help people come to
New York to have abortions from the
scary Red States over the weekend yeah
so it's like nobody nobody's rights were
taken away and abortion was not a
constitutionally guaranteed right in the
first place but they just lie and and by
the way now you have more personal
control by not mandating it from the
federal government you have more
personal control again you can move to a
different state also you could have a
little autonomy over your body and
decide when you want to have sex and all
that kind of stuff but I know that's not
hip these days anyway here's uh Democrat
former the woman tried to run for
president did not go well uh Minnesota
representative Amy Klobuchar she's on
CNN talking about abortion and again
there's just this confusion about
federal laws viability all that take a
look
say like you just said that you support
codifying Roe v Wade Road didn't Place
limits on third trimester abortions it
just allowed states to do so would you
support a federal law that bans
abortions after viability
what I support and I'll be very clear
about this is Roe v Wade which does
allow for limitations but it also
protects the life of the woman and the
health of the woman I think that is the
best okay so she's a perfect politician
she didn't answer the question at all
the question was about a federal law
would you support a federal law that
bans abortion after uh viability meaning
so now you're at seven months this this
baby I mean there are preemies that are
born at what four months like a little
bit after 20 some odd weeks now that can
survive but let's say seven eight months
would you want a federal law Banning
that so in essence let's just not kill
children that that can live let's just
not kill babies and then of course you
can't even answer it now the funny thing
is I would I actually wouldn't be a
federal ban on that either because I
believe the states should make the
decision which is exactly what we have
right now but they can't answer anything
honestly because they can give you those
again very thin veneer answers that all
sort of sound right so she just goes on
her little diatribe about whatever but
they just cannot answer anything
honestly the other thing that they're
very good at is keeping you upset about
things that have nothing to do with your
life so Barack Obama earlier he's very
concerned about climate change while he
lives on a 30-acre estate on the water
in Martha's Vineyard here's the elderly
man pretending to be president he's also
concerned about climate change although
he may have only moments to live
so first of all I think it is the
existential threat to humanity climate
change it's the most serious problem we
face as you
oh you old bastard you're the you're the
most existential problem we have these
people imagine thinking that Joe Biden
could do anything about climate change
it's just nonsense as I said before the
climate is or isn't changing there are
patterns things happen remember it rains
too much in California they tell you
it's climate change then there's a
drought they tell you it's climate
change and then Ellen DeGeneres stands
by a river telling you that you better
behave nicer to Mother Nature it's all
completely bananas but now let's get it
to something a little more sort of in in
the granular uh part of what's going on
politically right now we do actually
have a massive Scandal that is is
developing right now so you know last
week uh Hunter Biden pled guilty to a
couple tax evasion things he got a slap
on the wrist he's not going to jail as I
said many times this is the exact same
thing that sent Wesley Snipes to jail
but somehow Hunter Biden and the crack
and all the stuff he's not going to jail
but that's not really what the Scandal
is the Scandal now is that there are
text messages that are being leaked out
there's audio recordings being leaked
out the job that Hunter Biden had in the
first place as this consultant for
Ukrainian Energy company when we know
money was being filtered to him and now
going up to his dad it's all sort of
leaking out right now so what the media
did last week was they were uncover
right oh let's get him on some tax
evasion stuff that'll hopefully get
everybody to stop talking about it
here's White House spokesman John Kirby
and this guy what's with this guy's suit
I feel like he's wearing what did you
say you said it looked like three dogs
like in a suit something's going on with
this guy's suit here he is clashing with
a reporter over the hunter Biden text
messages
Ways and Means Committee yesterday
released documents their authenticity
nowhere challenged that included a July
2017 WhatsApp message
sent by Hunter Biden to Henry Zhao a
Chinese Communist Party official does
this not undermine
the president's claim during the 2020
campaign that he never once discussed
his son's overseas business dealings
with him no and I'm not going to comment
further on this
James James let me just let me save you
some let me say let me see let me save
you some breath if you're going to ask
about this I am not addressed I don't I
know you do more than I'd like you to
have I am not going to address this
issue from this Podium I'm just not
going to do it all right I'm not going
to do it
thanks guys have a great weekend
okay guys I'm not gonna talk about that
thing I'm wearing a very puffy suit up
here what do you want me to do I can't
talk about that thing do you remember I
mean we've played the clip for you many
times where Hunter uh where Joe Biden is
like I've never discussed business with
my son ever which on its face is just
complete nonsense is there any is there
literally anyone alive today who has any
remote relationship with their father
that has no idea what I do we have never
discussed the work he doesn't know why
I'm working for this Ukrainian Energy
company there's texts that are now
proving it right and there was a
voicemail by the way that leaked that
has proved it like it's just but Kirby
Democrat privilege right you get to wear
your big suit and I'm not going to
answer that question I gotta go here's
our diversity hire
here's uh it's James Rosen by the way is
the name of that reporter he used to be
on Fox I think he's on Newsmax now uh
here is White House Press Secretary
cringe Jean-Pierre and she's not having
it either when it comes to this whole
story
your statements from that Podium you've
stated that the president stands by his
comment from the 2020 campaign that he
never once discussed his son's overseas
business dealings with his son and you
stood at that Podium and you reaffirmed
that do you stand by your reaction what
I will say is nothing has changed
nothing has changed and I will leave it
there anything else I will refer you to
the White House Council this is not a
change I just answered the question you
asked you just asked me do does my
statement change I just told you nothing
has changed that's answering the
questions go ahead the president yeah
Stephen
I'm calling on your colleague right now
go ahead thank you to follow up on my
colleague is there anything that you can
say with regard to this text message and
what the president's son was alleging
was the president there or not I would
refer you to my colleagues at the White
House Council they have addressed this
and I refer you to them okay have you
spoken to the president about this have
you asked him whether he was there with
his son on July 30th this is not a
conversation that I've had with the
president again I would refer you to the
White House Council
with the president no did the president
speak with the attorney general at all I
can't I I cannot say if the president
had had a conversation with the attorney
general last night what I can refer you
to is the White House counsel's office
as it relates to the allegations they've
already addressed this what a great job
what a great job you don't have to know
anything you literally don't have to
know anything
uh what do you have for lunch today well
I'll refer you to the other guy and what
are you doing this woman is just
extraordinary it's just the job right so
you sort of don't even you can't even
fully blame her for being horrible
because in some ways she's actually
brilliant at it because she could just
stand up there doing nothing over and
over and over again so she's doing
exactly what they want her to do but
there the point is that there is a
scandal
uh there is a scandal that has happened
that finally seems to be breaking
through to a degree and by the way the
timing is perfect because it'll also
help them push Biden aside because they
know he's not up to running for
president and all that kind of stuff uh
but it again it's just interesting it's
like they cannot defend their ideas so
they whether it's climate change with
Obama whether it's abortion with Kamala
Harris any of these things they can't
defend any of their positions so they
say things that kind of sound good when
they have the tiniest bit of scrutiny
they completely fold or they call you a
bigot and a liar or you're leading
you're a liberal and you said something
we don't like you defended Free Speech
you're a big Hitman all right maniac
but more and more people are seeing
through it here's Chuck Todd and as you
know Chuck Todd is being kicked out over
at Meet the Press but I guess they're
giving them a couple more shows to say
goodbye with uh here he is on Biden's
abysmal approval rating
Biden's job rating sits at just 43
percent about where it's been since the
withdrawal from Afghanistan 53
disapprove uh a full 68 of Voters
including 43 percent of Democrats now uh
which is twice what it was in 2020 say
they are concerned that Biden does not
have the necessary mental and physical
health to be present in almost 70
percent of people are going uh yeah this
guy doesn't have it he ain't got it you
either got it or you ain't as Mel Brooks
once said and these mainstream Obama
Democrats right these are the Joe Biden
is the Vestige of the Obama democrat he
was his VP
he's the leader of the party and all of
these people their ideas are bad they
are counter to uh American uh I would
say philosophy and more and more people
are seeing through it and as more and
more people see through it the machine
has to come crashing down on them
because all the machine has is the
ability to lie to defend a bunch of bad
ideas if the ideas were good they would
be rising to the top but they they can
only push their nonsense uh using their
power that's what they can do but there
are a couple
people out there some of them running
for president right now who know when to
use power effectively who know how to
tell the truth and who know how to
assess what's really going on here
unfortunately we have not had a lot of
Republicans like that right Republicans
usually just kind of fold or you get the
pet Republican who gets the cookie on
The View you get that sort of thing but
Ron DeSantis running for president right
now he's not only going after the Dems
that's pretty pretty obvious going after
the wilsters and all that stuff but he's
I also trying to show Republicans you
can have a backbone you can have a
backbone as a ram like a ramrod as Joe
Biden would say and you'll actually be
rewarded for it this is a speech from
over the weekend
for far too long we've had a lot of
Republicans that get into office and
they're almost like potted plants they
don't want to lead they don't want to
put they want to follow polls have their
finger in the wind they do not want to
take on fights that are going to lead to
the media attacking them or the left
attacking them and so what they end up
doing is yeah you know they'll do a tax
cut here something there but they tend
to defer to the media they defer to
corporations and what that means in this
day and age is that the left will win
because they're going on all fronts
they're pushing their agenda through the
schools they're pushing their agenda
through Corporate America they're
pushing their agenda through an
unaccountable bureaucracy if all you say
you're going to do is sit there and only
deal with taxes and and certain spending
issues then you're giving away the game
so you need full spectrum leadership you
need to understand that the threats to
Freedom are not limited to what happens
in an election or even in the halls of
government but it extends far broader
than that we understand that in Florida
and that's why we've become the free
state of Florida because we've protected
this Freedom all across the board okay
so there's a reason I wanted to show you
that clip right after the Chuck Todd
clip so in the Chuck Todd clip he's
going look 68 of people basically think
that the Democrats kind of suck they
think that Biden's not up to the job
blah blah blah now what's the Santa
saying there he's saying well guys
there's a reason for that Republicans
usually suck so even though the
Democrats suck most people know it most
people aren't on board all of this folk
stuff once they really understand it the
Republicans that come in usually just
kind of fail and he's saying enough is
enough we will export what we've done
here in Florida all the way across
America and he's also taken some shots
at Trump saying that you know he's he
talked a big game but when it came to
actually fighting the machine he was
kind of limp when you are saying
that Cuomo did better on kovid than
Florida did
you are revealing yourself to just be
full of it nobody believes that and you
know why
all right
[Applause]
and you know why I know that because I
remember in 2020 and 2021 when he was
praising Florida for being open saying
we did it much better than New York and
Michigan and everyone was coming to
Florida and that we were one of the
great governors in the United States and
he used to say that all the time now all
of a sudden his tune is changing and I
would just tell people do you find it
credible do you honestly find it
credible would you have rather been in
New York during covid under Cuomo regime
or would you rather have been in the
Free State of Florida and I probably can
count the number of Republicans on my
hand in the nation who would have rather
been under Cuomo in New York and we know
that and so these are just uh frivolous
criticisms but in some respects I think
it shows that you know if you have to
make that argument then you probably
don't have very good arguments because
the reality is everything he said about
us for years about how strong we were
how good we were how we've delivered for
the state those happen to be true and
now he's trying to backtrack because he
you know views he needs to do that and
he's saying things that are false and so
that's fine if you want to do it I don't
think people are going to buy it so this
is what we're kind of caught between
we're caught between a bunch of
Democrats with the exception of what I
would say are the the minority Democrats
the Bill Maher RFK Democrats who don't
have any power within the party and the
Machine is actually trying to destroy
them and the parties trying to destroy
them and everything else you have uh the
Barack Obama style and then mainstream
Democrats who lie about all the issues I
think we've laid that out quite clearly
here and then on the other side now what
you have is Trump who we are told is is
somehow leading by 30 points or
something that's what I'm told by the
mainstream media but he now is lying
about virtually everything and I also
don't know anyone in the history of
politics that has been so obsessed with
attacking the number two guy when you're
the number one guy everyone's supposed
to be attacking you we're having a very
odd thing happening with this Republican
primary where everybody from the number
one guy Trump to the number seven eight
guy uh Vivek and everybody else they're
all going after the number two guys
something weird is going on there just
put a little pin in that but what have I
also been saying for at least six six
months when it comes to DeSantis and
this was well before uh you know people
thought maybe he was going to run for
president for a while but like well
before it was really in the conversation
I kept saying to you that what the
mainstream media was going to do is tell
you that Ron DeSantis is far more worse
far worse than Donald Trump right he is
going to be Hitler with a calculator so
Donald Trump was Hitler not very good at
his hitlerian stuff but he was mean and
he was a racist and all those things but
he was also an incompetent buffoon and
that gives a little bit of cover where
this DeSantis guy he's all of that stuff
but he's got a calculator and knows what
he's doing here's this little
compilation of the machine going after
DeSantis for being more dangerous than
Donald Trump
original Terminator the Sanctus is like
the T-1000 to veranda Santos is far more
dangerous than Donald Trump a more
disciplined extremist they're just like
oh well at least DeSantis isn't crazy
like Trump and I'm like no you should be
more scared of him than Trump he's more
Savvy he's more Coy and he doesn't have
the pitfalls that Donald Trump does
DeSantis is an even greater threat to
democracy than Trump he's a threat to
our democracy and a threat to he's a
threat if Donald Trump
becomes president again he'll be less
dangerous than Ron descent people think
oh we're gonna go for Ron Santos because
he's normal he's not normal as horrible
and grotesque as he is Donald Trump is
not as dangerous as this guy Ron
DeSantis it is beginning to feel less
like a governorship and more like a
regime he's running more to the extreme
than Trump on several issues so you guys
got it who who do they fear who do they
fear he's more dangerous than Donald
Trump I mean imagine more dangerous you
know our intern Michaela's here for the
weekend Michaela you live in
Pennsylvania but you're here in Florida
you've been in the free state for a
couple days now has has anyone attacked
you have you been under any sort of
threat is everything going okay the
meals have been good and you haven't
been attacked by an alligator or
everything's been yeah the point is this
is the best place to live in the United
States and everyone knows it and that's
why these morons vacation here and why
everyone's moving here and everything
else so now let me wrap this show up in
a nice tight bowl for you you've got we
just played we just played mainstream
media trying to take out Ron DeSantis
mainstream media where'd we start
they're trying to take out RFK Jr let's
jump back to Club random with Bill Maher
RFK talking about how the Legacy Media
hates him and hates his campaign
the Legacy Media is is
fiercely ferociously opposed to my
candidates saying oh every yeah
but somehow there was an article that
came out today a poll that came out
today and Forbes
that showed that I my uh favorability
ratings are better by far than any of
the other candidates and
um and I'm not you know bragging about
that but it's just curious because all
of that I hate to interrupt you but if
you're running for president you should
brag
that people lose elections sometimes
because they're too modest you know who
is not very modest Donald Trump yeah
that's a good point it kind of works for
him I mean not to that's promotion works
imagine if instead of Donald Trump
versus Joe Biden right instead of doing
that thing again and I know it would be
comfortable for a lot of us it would
just be like it would be like watching a
rerun let's do it again they're both
older everyone's lost the step nothing
will be remotely true on either side
we'll continue this gerontocracy we can
do that again or imagine imagine if and
this isn't going to happen unfortunately
on the Democrat side but imagine if the
Democrats took a guy like RFK I don't
agree you know he's he's worse on guns
uh than than I would be certainly I I
definitely have a difference with him on
abortion climate change a whole bunch of
stuff but I think you can clearly see
this as a guy who knows what he thinks
he's like ballparking the right stuff
and that's why he's making the rounds on
all of the scary right-wing talk shows
because everyone on the right loves when
there's like a decent guy on the left or
a decent Democrat to debate ideas with
and that's what this guy wants to do
right and that actually believe it or
not is the liberal the true liberal
position which unfortunately definitely
has nothing to do with the modern
Democrats because they have shifted the
Overton window to the point that if you
are a moderate Centrist of 10 years ago
they will now frame you as a crazy
right-wing Maniac I was on the fresh and
fit podcast big podcast with the young
people uh over here in Miami last week I
think we showed a we showed a clip of it
or a little image of it I want to show
you this one little clip because they
were asking me about my political
Evolution uh and I think we can tie this
together with Elon and sort of
everything we've talked about right here
you could see it right here this is so
Elon tweeted this exact thing so Ben I
don't know if you Ben saw it first or if
this is from after or whatever but you
can see in essence 2018 my fellow
liberal me and then you can see the way
the shift is going the fellow liberal
the progressive now he went bananas left
boys or girls everyone's racist blah
blah blah the me guy he stayed as close
to the center as possible then in the
third one down there in 2021 now the the
liberal is now known as awoke
Progressive and everyone else is a bigot
and the me guy has now in essence been
shifted right and the conservatives
going LOL you see I wasn't so bad after
this is a perfect illustration honestly
of what it is because I've always said
it like a lot of people haven't changed
their views just that the left becomes
more and more and more radical yeah well
they don't they have no sort of off ramp
you know at every moment where the left
could go all right maybe we should just
ease up let's think about what we Donald
Trump gets elected you might go boy
maybe there's something going on here we
should talk about maybe there's
something wrong with what we're doing
you know orange Hitler is in charge
maybe maybe we should discuss this but
they don't they get more hysterical but
the reason they do is because it's all
based on emotion all right you get it
though those guys get it and let's see
how the rest of this all plays out but
uh as I say once you see it you can't
unsee it that is the uh that is the
disturbing part of the red pill uh I
hope you've enjoyed the show today
Michaela said right before we started
this was going to be a 10 on my birthday
the rare I've argued impossible 10. I'm
gonna go out there and say it was a nine
nine I just I don't believe in
Perfection we are we are imperfect
beings we cannot create anything perfect
we can get glimpses the fleeting glimpse
of perfection but we can't hold it for
too long uh guys if you want to join us
for the post game show
reubenreport.locals.com right now we
leave you with a cold close uh Elon
versus the Zuck and again thank you for
all the birthday wishes and we'll be
back at it tomorrow ciao
ah damn I gave it the 99 and then I
screwed up right at the ah 9-7 I lose
point two uh it's me Monday over at the
report locals Community here's the one
that I put up uh that was not that was I
said that was the cold clothes damn
this was the meme Monday the first ad
for the Elon Musk versus Mark Zuckerberg
fight just dropped and I think that's
from The Avengers cartoon in the mid 90s
and now we leave you with the cold
clothes from MSNBC this is so profoundly
disturbing you just get ready to press
mute for the rest if you're gonna watch
for a second you're going to want to
mute this thing goodbye so um Josh as
I'm closing the segment do you want to
do some of those vocal warm-ups just to
sort of give us a sense of your range
yeah sure all right well Andrew
of all the songs which one do you like
okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and Drew Reynolds and I are gonna sing
together every night for the next four
months
[Music]